this is really really special this
recipe I've been drinking it since I was
like five years old yes it has a room in
it hello everyone my name is Sony I love
making delicious comfort food inspired
by my afro-latina background today tasty
challenged me to make a dish using
ingredients starting with the same
letter so let's see what letter I pick
all right let's do it I got the letter c
chuck roast carnita just so you know you
only have 15 minutes 15 minutes 15
minutes to shop all right so I'm gonna
go ahead and pivot to dessert because
dessert is easy and it's fast and
limited ingredients and I am going to
choose an empanadas what I know is what
I love I can fill it with anything let's
go all right so the base of an empanada
is going to be the filling so I need
something sweet I need a fruit to put
inside cranberries coconut cantaloupe oh
Cosmic crisp apples this is perfect this
is amazing these are gonna be super
sweet and they're gonna add a nice bite
and crunch to that banana so I have the
base for my filling we're gonna use
apples it's all so of course I'm gonna
use cinnamon this is too easy you should
have gave me a harder challenge all
right so I need something to kind of
bind me up banana together sweet
condensed milk I don't know what I'm
making but we're gonna taste it three
ingredients that any dessert is gonna be
ice cream so I'm thinking we got
chocolate chip we got caramel coffee
that's gonna be perfect for my Empanada
dessert I just know it so the whole
reason I chose up and honestly I knew I
could use cornmeal
so we're gonna grab that because that's
going to be my goal
cornmeal there's no cornmeal okay I see
what you guys did here I'm gonna use
corn flakes okay flour I still want
something or is there perfect perfect
coconut cream hey your 15 minutes is up
I think I got everything I needed so
I'll meet you back at the kitchen all
right everyone so I am back at the
kitchen and I am ready to get started I
got all of my ingredients with the
letter c and I narrowed it down to some
that I really think I can make something
special with so I got some coconut milk
my cake flour which is going to be the
base of my Empanada I had to get my
coffee ice cream of course tasty was
nice enough to give me some Pantry
Staples we have some water some butter
and some sugar let's get started it's
time to make the empanada dough and
we're gonna pour our cake flour into our
food processor next I'm gonna add my
salt of course and then I'm going to add
my butter my pantry staple and we're
gonna pulse this until the butter is
evenly distributed okay I always
struggle with this part
there we go now we're gonna pulse
so we're going for that coarse sand
consistency so next you're going to add
some water to your flour butter mixture
and you're going to pulse while you're
doing this so you want to add your water
in gradually
so my dough is coming together I'm going
to check the consistency just to make
sure it's right and then we're going to
dump it on the table and eat it this
makes me happy perfect empanada dough
from scratch so now it's time to knead
our dough so we're gonna dump it all out
I am happy that I chose empanadas
because I grew up eating them so we're
gonna get our empanada dough together
I'm actually surprised at how well this
cake flour is going because I've
actually never used it before but I
wanted to do a traditional Colombian
Empanada using the cornmeal but it
wasn't available so I'm pivoting to what
I know best this is gonna be a more
Puerto Rican or Dominican style Empanada
we use flour and the cake flour is
actually doing really well so now we're
going to take our empanada dough and
we're going to wrap it in Saran Wrap and
then we're just gonna let it sit for 20
minutes so after my dough is rested it
is time to cut the dough into eight so
I'm gonna go ahead and take my dough cut
it down the middle working on my muscles
you want them to be like little pizza
pies so we're cutting them into eighths
guys so next I'm going to take one of my
little pizza pie teeth and You're Gonna
Roll it into a little circle you want to
make sure our empanada dough stays nice
and moist so we're going to move in
we're going to put it under a towel you
want to make sure you're getting these
nice round balls that are even keep the
consistency together because we want it
to taste good but we want it to look
good too I like to roll Mine by hand but
you can also use a table you can use
whatever you like as long as you have
these nice little balls
so I rolled all of my balls and now it's
time to make our dish I'm going to take
a little plastic bag I'm using a
tortilla press but honestly you can use
whatever you have at home you can use a
rolling pin you can use a bottle of
tequila whatever you have you just want
to make these into nice circles so you
want to make sure you're going to press
nice and firm or however you're rolling
them out because you want them to be
nice and flat and you want a sphere that
looks like this perfect put that to the
side and then I'm going to get another
one going and while you're here you can
listen to your favorite music this is
like the most relaxing part of the
process in my opinion it's a nice little
workout okay guys so I decided on the
base for my Empanada I don't want to
just throw the apples in there so I'm
going to make a caramel from scratch I'm
super excited about it so I'm gonna put
all of my ingredients into my pot I
decided to use corn syrup because of the
seed and the corn syrup is going to help
me stabilize my caramel so you're going
to dump my sugar in there and then I'm
going to add my water a nice Pantry
ingredient thank you tasty so when
you're making caramel at home it's
important that you put all of your
ingredients in and you're going to cover
it you're not going to toss it up you're
not going to stir it because you don't
want your sugar to crystallize you're
going to let it cook and you're going to
take it slow and low so now that we have
this beautiful amber color I'm gonna go
ahead and add my butter in and then I'm
going to whisk my butter in and now I'm
going to go ahead and add in my cream
and you want to whisk really fast oh it
smells delicious so next you're gonna go
ahead and remove it from the Heat and
I'm going to continue to whisk because
it is hot until the caramel is a nice
smooth texture okay so now it's time to
make our apple filling I'm melting my
butter and I'm going to take my Cosmic
crisp apples that I sliced and diced and
just toss them in I'm going to coat them
in that butter I'm going to give them a
nice toss these apples are actually
really tasty they're going to give the
Empanada a nice crisp now I'm just going
to add in a touch of water the water is
going to help soften the apples so
you're going to get that crunch in that
bite in the Empanada but it's still
going to be nice and smooth so we're
going to let our Cosmic crisp apples
cook for about eight to ten minutes on
medium low heat so I'll be back when
they're ready for the next step now my
apples are nice and caramelized they
have a nice golden brown color they're
soft but not too soft so we're going to
take them and transfer them to a small
bowl so that they can cool down and be a
nice filling for my Empanada so my
Cosmic crisp apples are cooling it's
time for the next step we went ahead and
we chilled the apples and the caramel
because if they're too warm they'll
break the up and out of those now that
those are chilled we're going to take
our Empanada rounds and our this and
we're going to take a scoop of each and
we're gonna scoop it right in the center
next you're gonna get a nice scoop of
your apples and then you're gonna fold
over your at banana and there's going to
be a little bit of space between the
filling and the edges and you're gonna
press down now that our Empanada is nice
and filled I'm going to go ahead and
decorate the edges so I'm going to take
my thumb and I am going to make these
little flowers I call them and after
they're fried this will look really
beautiful but if you can't do this you
can use a fork at home and press down
too and at the end you have something
that looks beautiful just like this so
it's time to fry our empanada dough so
I'm gonna go ahead and take them and
drop them in hot oil one by one I've
never had a sweet epineau that I've made
at home so I'm really excited to see how
these come out so I'm gonna fry the
empanada dough until they're nice and
crispy you want a nice golden brown
color so I'm gonna wash them closely
because they only take about two to
three minutes to cook and then after
that I have a special surprise see so
now our empanadas are ready they are
perfectly crispy and nice and golden
brown so I'm going to take them out and
I'm going to let them rest on the side
oh my goodness I don't know if I can
wait these look so delicious these
empanadas are gorgeous they have this
beautiful golden brown color they're
going to be so sweet and savory I took
one of my C ingredients cinnamon and I
mixed it with some of the sugar that I
had in a pantry and I made cinnamon
sugar so while your empanadas are hot
you're gonna dust them with that
delicious cinnamon sugar my empanadas
need something to really tie it together
so I decided that I'm going to make a
coquito glaze a coquito is a traditional
Puerto Rican holiday drink it's similar
to a eggnog minus the eggs and I have
all of my ingredients to bring it all
together so I'm going to start with my C
ingredient my confection sugar and then
I'm going to add in my coconut cream and
these are actually all ingredients of
the traditional holiday drink so this is
why I'm so happy and then we're gonna
put in our condensed milk next we're
just gonna add in a little bit of
cinnamon and we're just gonna whisk that
together until it forms a nice glaze if
it's too thick like it is here I'm gonna
add in a touch of water to kind of
loosen it up this is really really
special this recipe using an epineau but
also being able to use coquito which is
a holiday drink I've been drinking it
since I was like five years old I guess
it has room in it so I'm done whisking
my coquito glaze you want it to be a
nice thick texture it's going to be a
nice Finishing Touch look at that
perfect this really reminds me of my
childhood it's perfect you get like all
the flavors minus the rum maybe I'll add
some in later so I'm really excited to
eat one of these they smell amazing it's
gonna be mouth-watering so I'm gonna top
them off with my coquito glaze these are
so gorgeous and I like to go back a
second time the more coquito glaze the
better my empanadas are all glazed up
it's time to Plate these look absolutely
delicious I can't wait to see if they
actually taste as good as they look but
I'm sure they do because I made them of
course I'm ready to try it but first my
final seed ingredient is going to be
this delicious coffee ice cream and I am
going to place it right on the side of
my coquito and for my favorite part of
the whole day I get to try my delicious
dessert let's see how these coquito
glazed cinnamon empanadas are and let's
go for it
foreign
and now I'm going to take a bite of my
coffee ice cream to just bring it all
together
that's actually delicious I taste the
cinnamon I taste the crisp apples the
cosmic crisp apples CC I have some of
that coquito glaze I have the coffee ice
cream thank you so much for joining me
on this super fun adventure using
literacy was a challenge but I think I
pulled it off you guys tell me what you
think in the comments what challenge do
you like to see me do next let me know
thanks for stopping by
foreign
[Music]